okay Andrew Griffith thank you for
talking to us
um it was your mini budgets that brought
Pension funds to their knees are you
going to apologize
well what we've seen today is the Bank
of England do their job they've made a
targeted And Timely intervention in the
market that's their decision but they've
done so working very closely with the
chancellor what our job is to deliver
the growth plan that we set out that's
going to deal with some of the
underlying issues of the economy and
remember the first part of that was to
give everybody
households and businesses confidence and
certainty this winter from the start of
October at the end of this week about
energy prices that's the big overhang
that's what we needed to address that's
why we had to come out with that growth
plan and from there we move into supply
side reform you know really trying to
tackle some of these long-standing
issues whether it's access to child care
making sure that that bypass near you
gets built so that you can go to work
and British businesses can be as
productive as possible so do you know
that acknowledge any culpability
responsibility for what is happening
right now in markets so almost
accidented run on Pension funds in this
country
well what's unprecedented is the level
of volatility we've seen in all
developed markets I mean the UK went
into this with a strong balance sheet
our GDP there's an outlier here on in
financial markets we've got a very we've
got a very strong balance sheet the UK
has the second lowest debt to GDP ratio
in the G7 the bank as I say has taken uh
the timely action that it does it's it's
its job to regulate financial markets
and then what the government's got to do
is to provide people with that
confidence so really big interventions
to help every single household with the
cost of energy if we hadn't done that Ed
just think about what the implications
would be in terms of people's confidence
and their cost of living this winter but
for a lot of people they're looking at
what what's happening in financial
markets and they see a storm and they
see a storm that started with that
Financial that fiscal statement last
Friday do you not take responsibility
for that no we we both know that we're
seeing the same impacts of Putin's war
in Ukraine cascading through things like
the cost of energy some of the supply
side implications of that and that's
impacting every major economy and just
the same every major economy you're
seeing interest rates going up as well
so as as we go to the same degree as in
the UK
every major economy is dealing with
exactly these same issues and the bank
of England has made this timely
intervention doing what it should do
what the government should do what the
chancellor and I are focused on is
delivering that economic growth plan
which is ultimately what's going to help
people it's going to give people the
confidence it's going to create jobs in
the economy and keep people in work so
that they can make it through the winter
benefit from that protection in energy
and continue to protect our standard of
living very last question do you have
any plans to change your plans that you
laid out on Friday for instance lowering
the top rate of taxes the IMF is
concerned we think they're the right
plans because those plans make our
economy competitive at the end of the
day that's ultimately what we've got to
do what we politicians are responsible
for is making the economic decisions
that will drive continued growth and you
know that one of the things that's
bedeviled our economy is our inability
to reach that top two and a half percent
rate of growth it's happened in the past
it happened before the 2008 financial
crisis we can get back to that but we're
only going to do so with the program of
supply side reform that was embedded in
the growth plan so no change no
acknowledgment that this was partly done
so to get on and deliver that plan
that's what I the chancellor and my
colleagues in government are focused on
is getting on delivering that growth
plan that is what's going to allow
consumers to benefit and in the meantime
we are protecting every household and
every business from the biggest macro
shock out there at the moment which is
the cost of energy we're protecting
people from that